you guys we only have a few days left
for you to get this very limited
Valentine's Day design if you really
want a shirt now's your time to get it
before the big day or a mug or us a
hoodie or a critic or so many other
things in so many different colors if
you haven't checked it out already you
really should go there to teespring comm
slash stores slash big mood because this
Friday is the last day that you can snag
one and then the design is going away
forever wherever we're never bringing a
Beck ever again and it's so cute it is
super cute this if you want it you
should really get it treat yourself yeah
link in the description hello welcome
back to big moon we missed you did you
miss us hi that's going Plus know we
need complements okay I get really
insecure when I don't get compliments
okay yeah okay all right yeah I like to
be roasted can you roast me yeah I have
a great personality yeah I just really
think the top comment on there was
thinking about like me not wearing dude
I'm a pants girl my vagina oh [ __ ] would
you say you're insecure about that about
what about size my thighs yeah I'm
greatly because we're talking about our
insecurities this episode
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm not so so excited to talk about that
yeah we had a little week guys we have
little business meeting business god
yeah I love that
high heels just to clock them in and
then we take them off we were Thomas and
that's it we were like oh what should we
talk about on this week's episode and we
were somebody was like in securities and
I was like I think it's late to be
honest you don't show like that you have
that much so I feel like this is gonna
be it nice and raw yeah human get ready
to peel us oh that's the key to being
it's not insecure yeah just be me we got
this figure it out you guys that's a
secret let's start with once we fixed so
far I mean like a physical appearance
one oh nice uh it was it was my ears
yeah you don't even give a [ __ ] now you
took that [ __ ] all the way back all the
time now yeah all the wait no wait I
mean here into the future with that [ __ ]
I mean I put my hair up and stuff like
what's you know whatever years okay so
when I was younger
okay oh my god it's so funny but when I
was eleven years old I remember being in
middle school and it was after school
and then this this kid was like running
by which I knew like we were
acquaintances or whatever he wasn't a
stranger so he ends up running by he
goes hey you have big ears and then he
just ran away and I was just like what I
have been
years oh my god I never knew this about
myself and it was just like just even
having my ear so I just like to have
like super super straight hair and then
like they would kind of stick out a
little bit like through through the hair
like this and I would remember it like
that was the biggest I would do this a
lot like just covering my ears with my
hair frequently and I just felt like I
had the biggest most gigantic Dumbo elf
ears in the world and it was one of my
biggest insecurities and I remember
early JK date-like JK party days
sometimes we would have to get messy and
stuff and like all the other girls would
put their hair up in a ponytail and
stuff and I'd be like guys can we just
not like can I not do that like I'm
really insecure about my ears and so I
say you got surgery on your ears and I'm
like oh so they used to look different
and I'm like what's the problem and then
I'm having this crisis in my head like
am I allowed to laugh at somebody's
insecurities but then why I got over it
though is because JK like they did like
make me realize it was the most
ridiculous thing to be insecure about
because they aren't gigantic Dumbo ears
away I know them like my perspective on
on myself and it was all because of that
one super like drive by calming parents
started hating them never let them I
hope so we got divorce yeah yeah Travis
you've got absolutely no idea what my
ears look like do you know if your lobes
are attached I have no idea I have
attached ones oh do you
security she doesn't have any time ago
she used to say like you can either have
pretty feet or a pretty face so it's
like well I feel I feel like I have nice
ears but then there's some other things
that I hate about me so it's like you're
so worried about that where I'm like I
have [ __ ] pointy elbows guys around
us doughy elbow dude pointy as hell and
if you think yours are pointy
this is like in Mean Girls when all the
girls like I'm so sad and she goes I
have really bad breath of the morning be
so deep because I'm like worried about
this is stupid I just didn't want to cry
in the first 15 minutes oh my god oh we
in there okay everything that I hate
about myself so all the haters know what
to like point out when they say I'm just
gonna list everything that I need help
because actually cater to me they bully
me if you just said the things you like
about yourself oh yeah then everyone
knows that all the rest on the table
bullying builds thick skin it's good for
you yeah being humble mm-hmm so I have
to go through things I hate I came and
start thinking about
we calm down I want you to poke my eyes
out so if my nose is playing - I feel
like I have a lot of pointy like like
sharp pointy ends yeah literally never
see my name show my nostrils make my
nose like so pointy and like yeah they
do this I kind of wish I could do like a
reverse its 2.0 people pay for yeah
literally nose naturally post on so I
mean okay what are the win listen and
soak it in yeah whatever you and [ __ ]
your mom high forehead like you know
what's it talk about my beautiful blue
eyes really looks like we're bullying
roaster she says blue but I got like a
swimming pool like buff llamas water
boiling lose yourself in my eyes [ __ ]
wallet blue we bully each other for an
hour straight until we get over is I
just solving it
alright Jess your time is over let's
[ __ ] get Gina oh wow I am very
insecure about my naturally big hips and
my tiny waist and okay when it wasn't a
good thing to have a big butt our big
hips do you member that I mean you know
it was always I didn't realize I'm
actually okay with my hips I didn't
realize they were big until I went to a
doctor he's like wow you got like the
hips at some child boring yeah no um
mine would have to be my super chubby
cheeks I have like big chubby cheeks
which is weird because like every guy
I've dated when I say like I kinda want
to get surgery didn't like reduce them
they're like no no those are my favorite
part yes like they grabbed me and they
squeeze like so that and then Gina my
nickname in high school was chipmunk
because I had such chubby cheeks that
that's what they called me was chipmunk
in might go off on them like you were
gonna lose your [ __ ] elbows for that if
we ever get to the concert we want to go
to the front of the stage sharpen their
elbows how do you sharpen your elbow
they literally sharpen it like very
sharp and then they strength them like
when you hit your cat you're like
calcium builds up anyways so I have a
really round face I wish I had like I'm
more like straight I mean like a v-shape
Jong like how they do in Korea
cuz like it's just all this is just
round like if you feel my head it's all
mine like Exodus would always be like
yeah all in my head I've gotten like
every name from like basketball head a
bowling ball like I'm in the like will
be standing in it it's perfectly round
all around so when you
lay down like a little flat surface
Gmail of like rolling off to one side we
create our bobblehead merchants would be
the most Gina and I have roomed together
like a few times and like before she
goes to bed she sets up this kind of
like u-shaped thing and I'm like Gina
what is that fun she's like oh so my
head is entire and carrying the [ __ ]
around me so sore so like it's just like
really round and like I just want like a
more like angular chin like jaw um and
if you guys haven't noticed my chin here
doesn't protrude as much me - that's my
current one - yes I thought you guys
were in that mute into that mewing yeah
I don't know anything about that
I remember that though well I told tip
about it yeah she told me but I found it
fascinating only I was like wow that's
actually back-trace that's crazy so if I
were to get plastic surgery now it would
be like to remove some fat here and just
so like angle my job what's that thing
called it it's called a v-line surgery
Oh buckle buckle fat yeah sir is that um
what else is there anything that you've
gotten over that you were insecure about
before uh I like I can I can't say that
this is like crippling you know no it's
me I mean like it's cool just things you
want to change yeah if I can change it
awesome if not whatever you know yeah so
amazing because I was telling you how
when I was going through our photos for
the photoshoot because I was editing
them I was like Gina's literally doesn't
need to be like oh yeah like ivory pose
like I was trying out heart the poses
where everyone's not blurry they're
looking the right direction they look
comfortable they look confident and I
had a heart like every single Gina was
like this [ __ ] and then she still wants
to re-edit
it's just years of practice and like you
know foot modeling and something I would
never know that you thought these things
about yourself like it's yeah you just
look gorgeous in every picture besides
your face mm-hmm what do you have
anything weird about your body size this
mess up here I don't know anyone looks
at it I would say let's see
so my hips are really big I wish my
waist was a little bit smaller but
honestly I think it's from like years of
seeing girls on Instagram you know so
they're all photos in the modeling world
- yeah yeah so either you're like you
have bulimia or your photo shopping and
then like you're just kind of constantly
surrounded by that so just having like a
regular waist that's kind of like a
little bit square yeah you're also you
creep it away right yeah yeah kind of a
bay area and then I moved to LA okay
yeah so and it's hard working in an
industry where it's just beauty you know
everything is all beauty let's see I
have really thin hair so if I like curl
me to like it looks like I'm balding
here but I'm not it's just really thin
hair look over here there's that and
then I but it's like all this stuff is
like I for me when it comes to my
insecurities I embrace them and when I
can joke about it and laugh about it it
takes the power away from people trying
to make fun of me yeah right yeah
certainly eight-mile that [ __ ] yeah like
Gina your face is around like yeah [ __ ]
yeah you know exactly what reference
you're talking about she's probably some
specific scene where Eminem is like the
line likes a climax of the movie I knew
that something you do with Eminem but I
kind of just stop there it makes like
thinking of like specific lines that
Marshall Mathers I was think about
Marshall first thing yeah so that's what
I do like yeah like it's it's not
crippling but I also make fun of it too
so people can't make fun like I'll say
comments like gene in your face it's all
[ __ ] big I'm like tell me something
new [ __ ] I've had this for 30 years
like something new you know how about
you both i am i drank physical so don't
get deep on me
oh okay don't cry don't ever am i like
literal number-one insecurity mental or
physical it's like my acne scars I had
terrible acne for many years and for
anyone out there if you cannot shake
your acne this is crazy when I was a kid
I figured out that soda made my acne
worse and as an adult it took me 15
years to realize that it was sugar that
was triggering my acne
whether it was fruits or even fruits
there's a couple of things I went to a
dermatologist in LA and she told me okay
you need to cut out sugar coffee dairy
and red meat
coffee yeah all of those things and she
said yeah and she said to detox your
body and then we'll slowly introduce
what is causing it so I have I eat for
the longest time I had terrible cystic
acne and I couldn't like pop them and my
old dermatologist in Virginia was like
you need to stop popping these and I was
like I'm not popping these I can't and
so when I got here the dermatologist
told me that this cystic acne was so
deep that it was destroying the cells
underneath my skin because and I there
wasn't any way for me to really treat it
it was my diet it was like an internal
cystic acne hormonal right yeah it's
from monel but it was activated by
certain foods and so I I remember going
to a dermatologist and they told me stop
picking at it and I like cried because I
was like I'm not and so it took me many
years to come out here and finally clear
it up your boy is like Chris how did you
do that it's it was sugar I completely
have cut sugar out of my diet sometimes
I'll have a little snack little tree but
it's like it builds up over the years
and it just it just like it would
constantly cause like these acne
flare-ups and you know what I wish I had
somebody to talk to about it oh oh you
know what you should cure eyes really
affect you mentally right yeah they do
and sometimes they can be so crippling
it's like you can't even leave the house
hmm well if you don't want to leave the
house but you still want to talk to
someone you can get some help with talk
space I actually downloaded talk space
not that long ago because I was
realizing that when I first got out of
my relationship I was like yes I am free
blah blah blah like I was on top of the
world and then you know a couple months
go by and I'm like okay wait but I'm I'm
kind of alone I'm feeling lonely now but
I don't want to constantly be texting
you guys like every negative thing that
comes into my head because I want us to
have a good friendship I don't want to
overload you guys with everything that's
bothering me so I downloaded talk space
it was super easy to do it and I
actually did not like the first
therapist that I got with but they let
you switch like his magic as you want
one of five thousand there they're so
amazing your preference so you get like
you first it comes up there's like three
or four of them that'll pop up you can
read their credentials or whatever and
then you can like swipe through them and
see which one you want you pick one and
you start talking them and see how it
goes
so that's what I did and I'm still
talking to this guy he actually uses
audio messages a lot and I love that
because it feels a little bit more
personable than just a texting part but
so I'm still doing that and we'll see
how that goes I'm enjoying using talk
space so if anyone feels like they want
to try it you can message your therapist
through text audio pictures video you
could literally send them a photo of you
crying and just be like hell you can
even a set up calls like FaceTime toys
or like phone calls to so they do that
in it's like a 30-minute session and
look you don't have to wait to your
weekly appointment like that was one
thing I was like saving that like what
did that feel like when I was actually
going through an anxiety attack and like
by the time I get to the appointment I'm
not feeling that way anymore and therapy
is like that's like what two hundred
bucks an hour yeah once in an hour do
mine is 250 yeah but with talk space
it's really affordable hello four very
flexible with scheduling okay guys start
2020 off strong with talk space it's the
support you need to help achieve your
goals at a price you can't afford and
you can get $100 off your first month
when you use code mood when you sign up
don't wait for another year to go by no
matter what 2019 was like set yourself
up for success in 2020 match with your
perfect therapist today at talk space
calm or download the mobile app don't
forget to use code mood for $100 off
your first month that's talk space calm
huh promo code mumumu
you can message them anytime you know
what makes me feel good save it
raise your hand America if you're broke
and you know I take it back I'm not
broke I like to save money I do like I
don't care how rich I get exactly I want
to save money so good to like see $100
or something off of the price oh yeah
because when you put in your honey coat
it shows up as that little read it like
it's like read text and it's like minus
$100 and 19 cents and I'm like girl
honey what is this what is this honey
that saves you money honey it's a
browser extension you can install on
your browser and when you are a check
out on your favorite online retailer it
automatically inserts all the coupons
that could possibly work for your
purchase that's right
Target Best Buy Sephora Etsy Amazon
oh yeah anything and I also love that if
it's a website that accepts two promo
codes it will find the best two codes
and put them on you get free shipping
and 20% off so I recently used honey and
it was to book my solo trip my Bora Bora
trip and I saved some nice moola I was
very very happy and I constantly use
this every time I'm online shopping I'm
always checking my honey it's yeah like
sometimes activate or deactivate it well
sometimes I'll see activate it but I'll
activate it when I am shopping and when
I do that I see all these codes pop up
and then it just takes a few seconds for
them to run through all the codes that
they have and then you'll find the one
that actually works and you end up
saving a lot of money I love it
ready money honey honey is brown it's 18
million users over two billion dollars
in savings it's just a click of the
button stop being like me and searching
macys promo codes just click the button
on your extension and let honey do all
of the work for you not using honey is
literally passing free money because
sometimes you forget you just be
ordering a little fast you know just hit
the button just hit work I'm ordering
from my phone like because it's a it's
an extension like sometimes I forget
like oh I have actually the egg to go
out you get back on your computer to
order it wait I have an app too honey
oh my god hey guys today it's free to
use and installs in just two clicks so
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash mood - join honey calm / save some
money mode mood yeah right okay so yeah
I I kinda was like seeing all that for
anyone that kind of has gone through
what I did with my like acne struggles
where I literally went to a professional
and they accused me of doing something I
was not doing and it really like bummed
me out because I was like there is
literally no help for me but you put
some time I completely cleared up my
acne and unfortunately I'm left with the
scars of my acne and it was such a oh my
god it it is by far my biggest
insecurity because like somebody is I
don't even know if some of you guys
knows I won't do my makeup and certain
lightening I won't look I really avoid
looking in the mirror well I won't do
your makeup and sort of what does that
mean they won't like certain lighting if
the lighting is coming straight down on
me I will not do my makeup overhead is
terrible yeah and so you won't apply
makeup I will not apply make it because
I can't look at myself because then I
get down on my so well like
significantly and so like when I was at
Smosh we would batch shoot episodes four
episodes across there's a time where I
said see you on a JK news shoot I was
like TIFF I just did something I've
never done before which was apply my
makeup mid shoot
I will only apply my makeup in certain
mirrors because when I see it sometimes
I would get really down and I just was
like okay well I can't handle it so I
just will like avoid it and shield
myself from it and I kind of I still
struggle with it but I'm we're so dealt
with it for one or two reasons one of
which being I am a lot more financially
well-off now and I am getting to a place
where I can confidently go get the
surgery that I need for it and surgery
yeah it takes a while
I never qualify for laser resurfacing
too dark yeah because it will it will
cause hyperpigmentation on my skin and
I've gotten injections before they
didn't do much for it but this
procedures micro-needling it takes about
a year I've had that yeah and it
basically it destroy it like damages the
skin so it I was going to ask if you
will ever tried
derma rolling I actually have a kid that
I've never opened I I mean I just want
to get it done professionally it's this
thing it's about six hundred dollars per
session and I'm just your voice just
getting to a spot where like I can do
things like that so I think what helps
me a lot is remembering I'm gonna take
care of this soon and I'm a big
proponent of like whatever your
insecurity is if you can fix it even if
it's surgery like go get it done
hey there's nothing wrong with making
yourself feel okay especially because we
were in a time in society where the
tools are available to do that but I
guess what keeps me hanging on is
knowing eventually it's gonna get fixed
and then - I started to realize it's not
that bad
like people are not constantly attacking
before I like I've always been insecure
like if somebody sees me in person
they'll be like Oh boses face is [ __ ]
up but I really never thought that do
and the fact I feel like you put so much
emphasis on it yourself - to where I do
notice it but then like when you never
talk about it I literally never thought
that active acne so I don't even think I
just like I don't know I'm just a ghost
of like whatever that was is still like
on you I think so you think about it i
yeah I and I just remember like when I
came out for my audition with Smosh I
was like so like ashamed because I was
like oh they don't like me because I
can't be on camera I remember calling my
mom and telling her yeah I'm here and
everyone's really nice but I know I
didn't get it because they found out
what I actually look like like that's
literally what I did and it was so bad
that two years ago this is where y'all
gonna laugh I told my mom that I really
wanted surgery to fix it and so I wanted
to file for disfigurement literally like
how I like seeing myself that is that is
my number one insecurity but I know that
I know that a I'll kind of get it fixed
and then be when I was at Smosh they god
this really sucked it was actually a
problem for me so once I finally got in
they did it they did series where it was
gaming and we had a webcam right up on
us I did not like that
it was bright lighting it wasn't always
flattering and the camera was right on
us and so when we would do edit so the
videos I had and it was when my acne was
active and the scarring was really bad
and I didn't know the right makeup for
me and so I was like I would cry because
I knew that that was going
posted online to a channel with 7
million subscribers and so occasionally
I would ask them to cut out those frames
and then it got to be bows you cannot
have us trash half of the video because
you didn't like how you look and also I
wouldn't touch up in between shoots so
by the end of the day my makeup was
completely off there's a camera right on
me and I couldn't do anything about it
and so I just accepted it if I have a
question so in that moment when you were
calling your mom
about like after you had your interview
with with smashing you thought you
didn't get it how did you feel the
moment you actually did get it that kind
of like invalidate that initial thought
no because in its so it's interesting
because like I try to be like very
introspective I know for a fact because
I remember where I was standing when I
made that call with my mom that I was
protecting mice I didn't know for a fact
whether I got it or not but I was
protecting myself from the failure of
what I thought would be to come and so
when I did get it like I was very happy
but I think it's almost like I was
trying to give myself a reason why I
wouldn't have gotten it and I was like
it's easy to blame my skin you know it's
really easy to so yeah that's that's my
number one but let's say y'all so I'll
dig real deep and figure out I can't
wait to see these these micro-needling
I oh wait and there was one other one
too sorry though that's a really deep
one but the other one too is uh I kind
of hated my gummy smile for a minute
like if I laugh it's like it's a lot I
felt like it was my mouth and so I
wanted to get you can get injections
forgotten smiles but what I you don't
even have a gummy smile though like you
have a lot of teeth well now that I have
not like you should really be insecure
about your
notice it she literally cannot because I
posted a picture of her and my dentist
commented she got great oh my god me my
doctor Danny Danny yeah cool so I sent
him a picture of bows and like dude look
at these chompers he's like dude they're
beautiful like I know right I like them
now but and also I've had retainers like
clear aligners for about six months so
it's kind of also pushed it back a
little bit but it was a little more bad
before and at one point I wanted to get
gummy smile injections and I didn't
because I realized that this thing that
I didn't like about myself it would
topple over a thing that people liked me
liked about me which was I have a very
authentic smile and laugh yeah and I
know that people like that and so I'm
like well I hate this but if I get Botox
here it will completely destroy that
thing that makes me more natural and
more appealing so I didn't do it and
then eventually I just got the [ __ ] over
it
mm-hm I relate a lot to the acne thing
when you were talking about going to the
doctor and there they were accusing you
of something that you weren't doing
because my biggest insecurity was in the
past few years like I have another big
childhood one but the one in the past
few years is I didn't know why I got so
bloated I did a whole video on SIBO and
stuff last year but because I finally
figured it out but for years I'd say
since 2015 was the last time that I felt
okay in my own skin because I just
started experiencing rapid weight gain
fatigue bloating constantly we're
comments were and because we're on
camera all the time again like with the
Smosh you know and on being on JK and
also on my own channel I can hide it but
on other people's channels you can't you
can't yeah there were just like she
looks pregnant why isn't she sucking her
gut like all this stuff and it was so
depressing and frustrating because so
many people offer you unsolicited advice
like oh you need to be working out more
you need to be eating this way you need
to be eating less calories and I was
[ __ ] which running three three miles
a day I was doing so much cardio I was
doing so much strength training I was
doing a hydrating drinking so much of my
body weight in water everything that I
thought I ever I researched could
possibly get rid of bloat was not
helping at all
I was eating less than 1,200 calories I
was eating clean Whole Foods I was just
just doing the most I could do and still
a rapid weight gain I got to the
heaviest I've ever been in my life last
year including when I was overweight in
high school
weirdly like my clothes still fit
because it was just this just my gut and
people were like oh it's age it's this
it's that or it's diet and they always
they always everyone's an expert when
it's not you and I was like man you just
don't know like how much I've like done
the thing you already that you're
telling me to do and I finally last year
was like I need to fix this there's
something wrong and when I and I'm kind
of a hypochondriac with like it could be
this worst thing ever but I was reading
a lot about gut health and I thought I
might have Candida because that's the
thing that's out there a lot and it was
matching a lot of the symptoms I had so
I went in to get tested for Candida it
wasn't Candida but it was something
called SIBO which is small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth and I've talked a
lot about it you can you know watch
those videos I've even talked about on
this podcast before but um just finding
the diagnosis was such a relief because
I had run the gamut on what it could
possibly [ __ ] be I was like is it my
blood isn't a vitamin deficiency is it
this is it that and it affected every
aspect of my life because at 3 p.m. I
didn't even have energy to keep going I
had to go to sleep why like I couldn't
stay up and edit my videos it was just
ruining my life and then finding out
that it was gut health along combined
with so I ended up taking antibiotics
years ago and then eating a bunch of
sugar or high carb diet and it inflated
the amount of bad bacteria and my gut it
took over my good bacteria and it was
causing all that bloating and then the
stress would be trying to get rid of the
bloating caused all the weight gain and
so then that was causing fatigue and
interfering with my digestive system and
all of that and making me very sluggish
and just not myself a moody I was
[ __ ] moody all the time I was like
felt like I was PMSing constantly it was
enraging all my hormones all kinds of
[ __ ] like I just didn't even know I
couldn't even remember my old self
because this thing just became my new
personality and my new like yeah it
really is like a second brain in there
it affects everything I was so much more
depressed high anxiety and I already had
those things but it just like inflated
it times a million and so working on
that finally finding the problem and
that was expensive because my health
insurance is terrible
I was thankfully and a place to be able
to finally find out what it was and then
going to a dietician a nutritionist that
specialized in gut health and taking all
the steps necessary I had to go on this
crazy low fodmap diet that was an
elimination diet to work basically I
couldn't eat anything and then I had to
slowly reintroduce yet Nikki Lee group's
dry ass lettuce and grapefruit and
pepper mmm it wasn't just not no dairy
no me I was already not eating dairy not
eating me but it was also like you can't
have onions or garlic or mushrooms or
like so many things that were healthy
dedicated if that was me then I would
just be bloated
okay so I was ready to accept that I'm
like this is just me I'm doing comedy
whatever [ __ ] my looks I don't give a
[ __ ] but then when I read about the
serious side effects to health wise
where not only was I being fatigued all
throughout the day and moody and not
able to express myself the way I wanted
to in my in the entertainment industry
but also it could cause it could get
into other organs and it can [ __ ] up
your kidneys it could [ __ ] up
it could cause gout and leaky gut
syndrome IBS it could it starts causing
other more long-term effects that you
can't just easily get rid of so that
scared me to him to like doing that and
that was my wife throughout the whole
time I was like eating that [ __ ]
crazy diet that I'm normally so against
that extreme of dieting cuz I had a bad
relationship with food and when I was in
high school and it was like a long road
of getting healthy with that so I don't
like extreme dieting but um I had to
because I literally felt like my health
was in jeopardy and the fact that I want
to have kids soon I wanted my body to be
an OK home for a baby to grow in I want
my baby to have a nice home interior
designed to this home to be nice now
crotch Goblin my crotch Goblin but um I
did lose 20 pounds less
I'm at like my a healthy weight now a
healthy BMI I feel good I have energy I
used to not be able to make it past 9
p.m. and now I can edit and do all my
things have my sex life back all of that
stuff my one in childhood was I was
pigeon-toed throughout my whole life and
now I see models doing that cause I got
made fun of like crazy you know that
drive-by kid yeah maybe I walked past a
group of people that were making fun of
the way that I was walking and forever
any time I walk past a group of people I
thought they were making fun of me of
the way I walked so later when guys
would check me out or whatever
my friends like those guys are checking
you out like no they're not they're
making fun of the way I'm walking like I
would just freeze up because I didn't
think I could walk right and even now
still if you look in videos vlogs or
anything if I get tired or drunk I go
back to walking all day Giunta
knock-kneed yeah and they made like in I
took ballet too trying to correct it and
my teacher would always yell at me
because I could never turn my legs out I
like the other girls and it was just oh
really that was a really long
decades-long process of trying to get
over and I'm just now feeling like I
feel like this year is my favorite me so
far like I I feel confident in the way
that I walk it people make fun of it I'm
like fine with it I'm owning it and then
as far as like the gut brain connection
I've never felt so imbalanced like I've
always felt so like chaotic and now I'm
now that I at least know and I'm have
gotten educated on how all everything in
your body is connected and how stress
affects every part of your life and not
just your health I am so woke so thank
you so is your comfortable like like if
you were to walk naturally comfortable
it's pigeon-toed yes I still to this day
have to remind myself to walk straight
hear my mom's voice in my head like feet
straight feet straight feet straight
because yeah because it doesn't just
affect this but it also affects my
posture so I have scoliosis and it hurt
it makes my back hurt all the time
if I'm not walking correctly it affects
literally one part of your body affects
all parts of your body is what I've
learned it's crazy because in Japan a
lot of girls do it on purpose because
it's cute you know I think you can be a
queen in the game best Beach my works ok
educate you ok
so best fiends is an app it's a game and
I have been a dick to shading or read
the paper she tell you I have been
addicted to this game since like three
years ago
2016 16 yeah yes four years ago
yeah wait how did you know that because
that's when I started playing it okay so
oh my god I am on level 252 and I am in
the towering treetops world cuz then
there's only two apps in my like gaming
apps in my phone that I'm addicted to
and best fiends is definitely one of
them so if you're looking for a fun way
to pass the time while engaging your
brain and enjoying breathtaking visuals
because I do enjoy that about this app
it's like the the what like the graphics
yeah it's really nice um yeah and so
right it's so fun because like you know
yeah long plane rides you just don't
even realize how long the plane right is
cuz you're just playing the whole time
yes so the reason why I love this game
so much is because it's kind of like a
puzzle but it's like a unique kind of
puzzle where you're trying to and so
they give you like these these goals to
achieve for each level and you have to
do the puzzle in order for you to
achieve this goal to get your best it
makes you feel productive it really does
I love it and then everyday if you check
in you end up getting prizes and then
like you end up they give you like keys
cuz then like these Keys open up these
like secret boxes they have characters
yeah you're getting new characters and
then you get diamonds I really love this
game so
best fiends updates the game monthly
with new levels and events so like these
events it's again like they're giving
you these type of goals to achieve with
your puzzles and stuff and then they do
it seasonally too so even the best
fiends so you get the little characters
that have special powers and that's what
you use to achieve this puzzle I like to
complete this puzzle and so during the
holidays and stuff they'll have like
Christmas theme want like gingerbread
thinking best fiends or whatever it is
all right
so engage your brain with fun puzzles
and collect tons of cute little
characters they are really cute yes it's
so with over 100 million downloads this
five-star rated mobile puzzle game is a
must play so download best fiends free
on the Apple App Store or Google app or
sorry Google Play that's friends but
without the are so best fiends like I
said I'm on level 252 I'll brag about
walk you know what while you're walking
that walk I noticed your hair yes very
pretty thank you and smells great and a
part of that is probably because a
function of beauty which has been my
favorite shampoo and I am picky but my
favorite shampoo for the past year it's
so cool they customized everything so
you take a quiz and and then you fill
out like if you have curly hair or
straight hair or what what your hair
type is they have shampoos for every
hair type the custom formulated for you
so you put your hair type then you put
your hair goals like what your what you
want your hair to be so like more volume
as what I wanted some people want to get
rid of frizz some people want to thicken
their hair some people want a you know
whatever your hair just cour itchy scalp
they have a special formulas for each of
your hair gold can also target multiple
at once yes right which is what's great
which is where the yeah was a boy the
custom part is so key to that because
like you can go to stores and get you
know something for one of those yes but
to have all of it in one shampoo is
amazing also you get to pick the color
and you get to pick the scent and I
picked black and eucalyptus because I
like the black sparkly shimmer
it makes me feel badass and then also
the Sun is eucalyptus because I like to
de-stress in the shower and it's very
distressing to smell eucalyptus and they
also put your name on the bottle my
favorite part you feel special like I
got a whole bottle made for me exactly
there's so much in the bottle - I've had
mine since we started this podcast in
the same time last forever it's going
yeah a lot of product in one bottle yeah
and you can get set so you can go
shampoo conditioner yeah it's it's
awesome so to get started right now go
to function of beauty calm /big mode to
take your 4 part hair profile quiz and
save 20% on your first order don't spend
another minute in hair misery because
you deserve better than that go to
function of beauty.com slash big mood to
let them know that we sent you that's
function of beauty calm slash big mood
if you want to smell like me get the
paint the peach one like you smell like
peach yeah you do I kind of want it so I
feel like we've gone through a lot of
physical insecurities but what about
deep [ __ ] come on cry Jes I mean okay so
for Lyon I think mine's kind of obvious
because you know I'm 32 I'll be 33 in
the summer I'm single now
childless one of my insecurities is will
anyone ever really truly like this you
say that like it's a bad I mean
depending on how you feel about it but
you saw yourself as like a family person
I never kind of did but then I think
maybe society makes me feel like oh well
if you're at this age and you still
don't have a husband and you don't have
children you don't have like I mean yeah
maybe you have friends but also your
families what really matters so like
what do you really have or like so I
guess I worry that I'm not actually
lovable because I still don't have like
I still never really found my soul mate
and I'm like getting older so I get a
little bit worried sometimes like oh
will I ever really truly hire so young
and to you have finally like discovered
like who you are and what you like and
what you're not willing to deal with and
I feel like that's so important to do
before you find your soul mate I mean we
were talking on a different episode
about how the tip is discovering it now
and like you know that her and Casey are
going through that together which is
but like to find it before you find your
Swami is even better it makes the
relationship so much smoother and so
it's it's really I think you're in a
good spot but I guess there's a lot
though like it comes from my mom - so
like my mom being a drug addict and like
not ever really being around I didn't
have like the love of a mom or like you
know just that really strong love so I
just kind of feel like it's it's been
ingrained in me since I was a child like
oh I'm not lovable she wasn't there so
like who's really gonna be there you
know you know we love you right just
knows I would kill me so I think try me
and then I think a part of the whole mom
thing too is like when I'm meeting guys
they're like when I do find someone that
I'm interested in then I have to tell
them I have to explain to them like oh
my mom is a drug addict like all this
stuff like that's a huge insecurity for
me too like to get close to people to
tell them like what I've been through
what my background is and things like
that and I know some other people's
lives and stories are way worse than
mine so I definitely don't want to be
like on the worst and discredit victim
at the same time it's just it's hard
because the I did date this one guy
several years ago when I was telling him
that and then telling him that I did
drugs for a little while to myself and
then I just felt like all like all of my
past to him was just like whoo oh my god
like who are you isn't for you yeah it's
just but it is an insecurity that that I
definitely carries like my past you feel
like damaged goods yeah I think that's
well that was definitely yeah thing
literally we'll just think she actually
relate to this a same thing yeah because
I felt like damaged goods because I was
a single mom and I was like and then oh
you know this past stuff like where I
came from and stuff and I just felt like
ooh that's why I told KC I literally
told KC that something like hey you know
it's okay you can run it's okay
I've done that before - yeah guys are
making me cry because I love you guys
I'm Way ahead of you feeling unlovable
is just like so heartbreaking I'm just
like [ __ ] you're so sweet you guys are
both like so good hearted and I really
want to get inside of this hard show
that Jeana yeah sure let's hear it from
so I can actually relate to you because
and you guys you guys about this before
so they're like there are times and I'll
be dating someone right and there's this
guy who like dude his family's like
father went to Duke University right
like wealthy family very like donuts
have a family of like if they were to
drive through a bad neighborhood they
would lock the doors you know and then
I'm the one who's like I live in that
bed Jeana got the window down and like
heat like he like he's a he's a he's a
he's like he's a very successful and
like beautiful and like family dude like
every every Christmas they take like a
family portrait like that's like old
money right and a part of me
surprisingly got a little bit insecure
because my life is [ __ ] wild you know
and I didn't go the the typical route of
like an Asian here that went to college
that graduated it has a good degree and
like works in nine-to-five and stuff
like that and I talked to him and I was
like this is not action I didn't talk to
him I talked to you guys I was like this
is like what if I'm not good enough for
this family you know like what if they
meet me and they're like what the [ __ ]
is this like they probably do drag
yeah exactly exactly like blew our minds
because that's all the [ __ ] that we
think is badass about you plays video
games for a living she like knows like
she's like street smart like her own
modeling agency for time there's all
these cool things about you your wild
life is what attracts me to you I'm like
that's so [ __ ] cool and that's what
he liked me for - you know he's like
because before it was like he dated like
cookie cutters and he was like I'm bored
out of my mind and then now he's like
you're amazing and stuff like that but
we had have conversation we had
conversations where he's like I'm
actually kind of scared to see what my
parents would think of you yeah so it's
like I think it's feeding into your sick
insecurities yeah so that remark kind of
like stuck with you yeah yeah you
shouldn't have said that out loud yeah
but I mean like you're sharing with you
I guess my parents like my dad told me
shut up you can bring a dude home with
like tattoos all over his damn face as
long as he's good to you I'm happy as
long as you can see care of you I'm
happy my parents are the easiest people
to meet because they will love you so
long as you're taking care of me
something I don't realize that that's
how Casey's parents are as well
because I can relate to your fear as
well because before meeting Casey's
parents I felt the same - because I'm
like dude you grew up in the house like
a trailer a mobile home yeah in
apartments and I'm like you grew up in a
house if you're actually I was just and
they're not just that but like you know
his parents they were pretty well-off
like so I was really really intimidated
to meet them especially single mother
and an Asian family so I was just like
not yeah I'm not Asian hair right but
yeah so then like in the meeting them it
was kind of like I guess how your
parents are they were just so loving and
accepting as long as it like there as
long as their son was happy so my god so
beautiful thank you I love you so like
it was um so it was it was kind of
strange for me to like because now I
went from dating like [ __ ] whatever
to like a professional like yo I
wouldn't I wouldn't expect miss Gina
darling to be dating this type
yeah so it was like a really strange
shift for me and then so like I had to
hit up the girl so I was like and I
shamed I told I don't shine like yo you
guys I need you to help me out I'm
feeling a little insecure and I told him
I was going on and they just like rain
like love bombs on me and it was amazing
like and then I was like okay yeah you
know what that [ __ ] you know I am that
[ __ ] like I didn't go the typical route
but I've I'm successful yeah yes yeah I
carry myself I sitting at the same table
girl exactly right like I'm comfortable
now you know and there and then like and
then I realize that my like I so I can't
as a child I grew up in a well off
family we had the big house multiple
cars and everything and then what I left
that family we're more like a
middle-class family and um and then I
realized like my my dad came from
nothing like [ __ ] rock bottom and now
he has a huge house multiple cars he's
amazing and I respect that
more than old money right right and I
talked to my dude at that time too and
he was just like you know I agree with
you because like like my dad worked so
hard and me I came from not privileged
you know I built everything myself I'm
here I've never had to do anything that
I was ashamed of to get here you know
and like I thought that was those and
that was like a brief moment of
insecurity and at the same time it and
like on a lighter note have you guys
ever dated someone like it's them in the
beginning and you're just like oh my god
we talk every day and we're just always
talking and then there's one day when he
gets too busy so instead of like 500
texts I'm getting 491 I'm just like and
I'm just like what's going on
woman yeah it was that were the other
300 text the other nine text where's my
text message go in right I'm scared
so at like and that's like because and I
had to talk to the girls about it to you
and they're like Gina
it's called someone getting comfortable
and like settling in and like finding it
was also like Gina do you know what his
job is
yeah that he was actually texting you
during work to begin with her was insane
yeah he has very very difficult job oil
and like Jim doesn't like change doesn't
I need attention it's because they gave
you this and they and you thought that's
what you were getting you're like oh I
understand what I'm receiving now and
then you're like they took it away
alright I don't like change
I'm baby okay I don't want to beware of
a Gina sign there's someone else I know
he doesn't care a new boy doesn't like
me anymore the girls like Gina what the
[ __ ] who is this hold on here hold on
this is not the same [ __ ] we a building
the table come on and then so because
it's like what's the thing for me is
like when things shift I get kind of
like you didn't choose it I didn't
choose it yeah and I'm just like hold on
like this kind of freaks me out a little
bit you know and I think it was justice
said he's getting comfortable he's
settling in and I'm like okay okay maybe
you're right
and then so like I'm gonna be a stone
wall not let it bother me you really
thought that I'm like yeah guys that's
really cute and then like he just
started dumping affection on me again he
goes what ever happened to you being a
stone walnut thug so yeah so so that
insecurity like it's I think it's
natural you know
but also it was an expectation that you
had because that was what had been said
and then it changed without you knowing
that it mean all guys do that but I
think the manage it the meaning is that
you actually like this guy right yeah
like you've been through several
relationships we were like take them or
leave them yeah this one you're like oh
wait I actually do I don't want to lose
it yeah so pretty that's pretty common
insecurity that's what it is
yeah even a chat I'm like I'm a [ __ ]
trapezes so that was a very like for it
and feeling for me and then that's when
I realize like oh I think I really like
this guy you know because it's someone
that yeah now that I've dated people and
I know what I want and like all right
holy crap lose what I want and I have no
idea what to do with it you just have to
enjoy it yeah right and then so it's all
gonna go away one day I mean we're all
gonna die Nikki that made a metaphor
like it's kind of it's like it's it's
nice for him to see like this like a
crack in my arm yeah you know like wanna
stay yeah it makes him feel special yeah
like everyone else just gets the armor
and he gets to see a little bit in yeah
he's the acceptable she so like he was
and it means more because it's like
she's not really she's not normally like
this you're not just a machine person
that gets walked on you know so like for
you to feel that way or feel a little
bit of like oh no is like it's a much
bigger deal because you have such a
strong armor and you are so
thick-skinned and you are such a like
empowers like I bring the [ __ ] table
[ __ ] table to his family I made a [ __ ]
I would i chiseled it myself [ __ ] I had
to learn to chisel and I have to make
this and I went to the woods to get the
wood for it chop that tree down I
realize like if I were to ever like if
we were to go all the way and like get
married I'm marrying him if his family
doesn't accept me like if he loves me
enough and he would kind of like fight
for me too you know what I mean and like
if he doesn't then it's not meant to be
and both and I heard that you had some
deeper things you wanted to discuss I
mean no we can just skip over me oh I
don't have anything
oh you don't you just wanted to hear our
Juice so it's just it's actually like I
have to be honest like I was really
thinking because I mean the one that you
discussed already that is a lot yeah
that's that's definitely like my
absolute number one but yeah I I've had
I cannot express enough I've had a
million insecurities in my life and I
have worked very hard to abolish them
because a lot of them are just
restraints that we put on them ourselves
and for most of my life I was putting a
lot of restraints on myself and I've
since lifted almost all of those because
I work every day to do that but there is
one that lingers and it's a it sounds
really dumb but it happens all the time
is I'm very messy I'm really messy and
very insecure about that and it's gotten
to the point that and I think that once
this podcast comes out I will have quit
my job which is something that you know
i-i've just recently got this really big
job and I I want to like hold off on
saying it because like her kind of like
security reasons I haven't like said
where I work or what I do
but my job is incredibly stressful it is
by far the most stressful I job I ever
have had or probably will ever have
essentially I am up at 6 o'clock in the
morning dealing with some of the biggest
talent agencies in the world in New York
City that are literally yelling at me
about you know something happens
something going wrong
I'm literally working from 6:00 a.m.
until 6:30 p.m. and on top of that I do
everything with you guys I started my
own company last year I got poached by
CAA to do some work with them and every
single day once I get off of work at
6:30
I have a meeting coming up that usually
lasts until 9:00 so I am busy stressed
and tired every [ __ ] day
and I come home I drop my [ __ ] on the
floor and I get in bed and you never
find time to clean it all up you just
you never do when you're that stressed
and like not necessarily depressed but
you just you're trying to get through it
and I it is not healthy to work the way
that I've been working but I've been
doing this for the past year to get to
the point that I am now where I can quit
and I think that's okay whether you've
got to do that for a year or two years
like my stepdad worked two jobs for the
longest time so that he could have
enough money to pay for to have a nice
house so that custody would let his kids
stay on the weekend sometimes you have
to do it to get to where you are and so
I chose this but in that I I don't
always when I have free time I don't
want to spend it cleaning and so it
piles up and it piles up and it's gotten
to the point where the other day I told
my boyfriend I was like and honestly
it's really like not that [ __ ] bad
it's really not because I've been to
your place No so okay so initially you
said that you're you're just like no
it's fine okay so back like context here
is that I was really late at night I had
to pee so bad before I went home so I'm
like please I need to use the restroom
she was like [ __ ] no not right now I
haven't cleaned and then I was just like
no it's okay like I promise I don't care
I don't judge it's all right like if you
want I'll close my eyes and you're just
like you're gonna have to close your
eyes and I'm like yeah no worries I'll
close my eyes but then when she actually
opened the door she's like TIFF I'm
kidding you could open your eyes and I'm
like no I'm give you my word yeah I went
oh yeah we did we had been drinking and
then so I went to the bathroom and I was
just like trying to like literally just
stare at the floor I was like I'm not
gonna look at anything or anywhere
there's got skid marks on it between her
toes and I'm like Bose I need help I
don't know how to get out and then so
like finally she's like just open your
eyes and I'm like okay fine and I'm like
this is what you are wearing what
happened on the floor it's that mean for
scope for viewers I could clean
everything up in one hour Vic straight
up it's not even bad yeah and so but for
me yeah and this is exactly what the
insecurity is my my boyfriend bought it
up to me because I've been getting with
the job getting harder and harder and
more things approaching I have just been
cleaning less and less and when
and I came and like he came in and he
was like what would this is what you're
upset about and like I felt like deep
shame and he started talking to me about
it he was like why and he was like is it
because you're so put together on the
outside that you feel bad that you know
you have a bot an Amazon box over there
or you need to take the trash out and
I'm like I guess so because like really
all it is is like a coat that's on the
couch two pairs of shoes in the living
room mail on the table and it's all
stuff that I could just collect and I
think that's why I feel so much shame
with myself because it's like just
[ __ ] get up bows and clean it up but
with my day-to-day schedule yeah I don't
but with this new development your voice
got all day to clean to chill to do the
damn thing so yeah that's why I'm like I
feel like it's corny but that is mine
that is my biggest like internal
insecurity I couldn't walk through my
room at one point same I hope for me to
be a clean person I was a [ __ ] slot
and my parents always called me that I
had to make Pyle a pathway to my bed
because it was it was just that messy
all the time my car was a [ __ ]
trashcan it was taken away when I was
nine years old because I wouldn't clean
my room
because my mom never taught me I had me
for not having clean room but I was
never taught how to clean my day was the
most depressing birthday of my life
because I was sleeping on the couch Oh
usually like I was just a custom is how
I grew up I don't know it sounds
entitled or whatever but I usually would
get a cake and like actually celebrate
my birthday and then my ninth birthday
all I got was a cupcake with the little
candle between your room [ __ ] this know
that my mom gave me like a like a
birthday card or something and I
remember I was just crying my eyes out
that night cuz I couldn't even sleep in
my own bed I was so [ __ ] sad weird
thing is you guys were never taught to
clean the reason why I'm messy is
because I grew up militant like so it's
rebellion for me so I'm talking like I
had at like at the age of like 4 or 5
I'm mopping
sweeping separating everyone's mails and
delivering it to their bedrooms I was
dusting every day and they were like so
the family that I got was before was
[ __ ] insane right yeah that's why I
left that's part of the reason why I
left and it was crazy at the point where
they gave me a note pad where it's write
down what I did at every certain hour
Wow 4:30 you're an employee of the
family if I did it I would get my ass
[ __ ] beat like and I'm not something
like like just spank you
I based up in my arms down the [ __ ] oh
my god [ __ ]
so not Nicki dis that's what they do
hate you yeah oh my god when I was like
[ __ ] this I'm out and I moved out I was
like this is oh my god I can do whatever
I want you know like it was just like it
was so nice so it's like people are like
cheating yourself lady no I know how to
do everything like I did everyone's
vomit I yeah yeah really a little bit it
wasn't that extreme but then after I got
my room taken away my stepdad is like
that where he's so [ __ ] OCD with
everything he had to like control
everything and everything had to be
perfect and after that like that's when
they kind of made me their Cinderella
and I would have to be cleaning every on
the weekends he would make me clean the
bathroom three times and it wasn't just
like regular like cleaning the bathroom
[ __ ] I had to get a bucket and wash the
walls and coming behind the toilet like
literally everything I'm surprised I
didn't pass out because of all the
chemicals I was using no I totally
relate to all of that I mean the pigeon
toe one when I was younger and feeling
like I didn't have friends because of
that because basically the popular girl
at my school like told everybody that
they couldn't be if they were friends
with me they weren't invited to any of
her parties and she threw like all the
good parties and she would basically
invite the whole class except for me it
was like I was very like isolated and
alienated and didn't realize how much it
affected me until later in life but so
that would that was a deep one of like
the pigeon-toed nice but also just
didn't in family life like feeling like
a very achievement oriented like where I
real
as I only felt loved if I achieved
things therefore I felt this I feel that
a lot of anxiety as an adult because I
feel like if I'm not doing a good enough
job now and I never feel like I'm doing
a good enough job I'm actually a
recovering perfectionist because I
really human being a human Julia's heard
a lot from you Nikki like you oughta
know so much for me to know you read a
lot of books I do read a lot of books
hey you two I think that that was like
the ultimate achievement was getting
past this like like whatever was causing
me to constantly be so depressed and
like hard on myself and yeah I mean we
were I mean I don't know there's a lot
of like little issues in here and there
but I I think I felt like I always had
to prove myself and there was always
like a chip on my shoulder to like like
get attention and love from your parents
I think that's where always stems from
and then there was a huge disparity
where like my brother would just get it
for being him for example the cleaning
triggers me because I though I was such
a good kid didn't do drugs got straight
A's like everything I could possibly do
to like be a good child for my parents
and I remember the first time I started
making some friends was in sophomore
year of high school freshman year I only
had internet friends sophomore year this
one girl reached out to me and she was
like hey let's hang out let's do this
and I was the first two weeks of school
and I just finally was like I have a
friend and my dad decided that was when
he was gonna ground me for the first
time of my life in my entire life
because I didn't clean my room which I
had never done and was not taught how to
do and I would get yelled at but I just
didn't know how to do it he's like okay
you have to have your room cleaned by
the end of the day I was like okay and
so at like 2:00 o'clock I was moderating
the M&M board I was it was like we had
okay I'm showing up because to me I feel
like it's a job I was very committed
like if I say I'm gonna be somewhere I'm
gonna be somewhere I'm into your animal
yeah exactly so I was like at this
madres meeting my dad decides to come
home from work early he didn't tell me
he was coming home from work early he
said by the time I get home from work
which is usually 5:00 p.m. you better
have your room cleaned okay so he gets
home at 2:00 what I'm having the meeting
and he grounds me he takes away the
internet takes away the phone he can't I
can't leave to Holly wait you're meeting
like did you finish your meeting
no he plugged it and he and I tried to
write an email to him like saying why I
thought this was unfair and like kind of
making a presentation of like why like
you said at the time you come home but
you didn't say you were coming home
early so I thought my deadline was 5
p.m. but you but you came home with two
I felt very tricked and um and it was
deep because it was like the first time
that I felt like I had a friend and then
I felt like he took that away from me
and didn't care that he took that away
from me and then my brother
five years later found this but by the
way I was grounded for two weeks
straight with no internet no phone no
thing I felt like I lost my entire
social ID yeah for my brother who was
always very popular he was an athlete he
was on the baseball team and the
football team and he always got praised
by my parents because he was such a good
athlete he gets grounded the same
punishment grounded for two weeks no
phone no internet no nothing no leaving
the house for you want to guess not
clean not cleaning his room for drinking
alcohol on campus oh my god the same
exact punishment they're always nicer to
Boise he's Indies and they were like oh
we're gonna carry on the bloodlines it's
true right that's right so I that was
always a thing we're like I always felt
like I had to prove myself but then love
came so easily for my brother and yeah
it's been like a very internal struggle
and I realized that because I wasn't a
planned pregnancy that I beat there was
always jokes like oh yeah like you were
in UPS and so I would make jokes about
it like oh yeah I was in UPS and my
parents didn't play me and my my
therapist be like you can't say that
anymore like you think of yourself as
being a mistake that you have to prove
that you're that you deserve to be on
this earth and I'm like oh my god I do
like
really felt like my whole life I was
like no I'm supposed to be here and that
was like a huge thing to get through my
parents did not mean to do that my
parents are amazing they're [ __ ]
loving ass awesome parents I mean
there's nothing I have against them at
all they were doing the best they can
they could they were like very young 20s
when they had me but yeah those little
things that happen in your childhood
that you don't realize yeah form the
fester and form all these bigger
insecurities later in your adulthood you
just think oh I'm just [ __ ] up right
here you know theatres there's some
digging you can do to unroot those
things and like work on them that I
didn't realize could be worked on yeah
that's so true
kind of like with Tiff's or she was like
as an adult she's like I have big years
and then she had to go back to [ __ ]
Trevor and you're like Travis [ __ ] yeah
no that's true
um began to dig deep in they know I'm
like see the best for like Maps honestly
it's one thing for you though that I
realize that my my um I had to teach my
dad this too you teach your kids to be
successful and achieve all these things
but you have to teach them how to fail
too right when they fail something they
don't freak and then it's okay and you
can fix it exactly like you can overcome
the failure not like don't ever fail
exactly you're here to try yeah well
speaking of parent like for me my like
my one of my biggest insecurities is
repeating the same story with like how I
grew up and how I was parented that's my
biggest fear
oh you don't want to be like yeah so I
don't want to be like my stepdad and be
OCD and be controlling and be a
perfectionist which I definitely have
those traits in me and sometimes I'll
like it will come out with Casey and
with Isaac and after it happens like
when the moment when it's happening I'm
not realizing that I'm doing it until
after and then I end up feeling so
horrible about myself cuz I'm like [ __ ]
I'm doing the same [ __ ] that it was done
to me that like was really traumatic to
me I'm like [ __ ] what am i passing it on
so now I think I've gotten better about
it because I've been trying really hard
to be mindful and not do that but you
know I'm sometimes I'll slip up and like
this happens a lot like if I'm teaching
Isaac something like for example just
the most recent thing
I was teaching him how to fold a fitted
sheet oh yeah yeah hard it's hard
yeah years old nice no not if I can do
that I just shove it yeah I was teaching
him how to properly do it and this was
the first time that I felt that I was
teaching him with patience and I was
actually calm and like trying really
hard to like not be too perfectionist
and try really really hard to let him
make mistakes and let him figure it out
because I tend to just take over and
just like see this is how you do it and
like not let him learn yeah so um and
this time like I still did it a little
bit but I was really proud of myself
that I didn't do it the way I usually do
it that's awesome so I'm like [ __ ] like
I'm working really hard on not repeating
the same story like that's one example
and like another example is um mainly
with cacey
so like I've talked about on this
podcast before like our our marriage our
entire relationship it's been really
rocky I mean we love each other very
much it's just that we haven't been able
to understand each other until recently
and so for me and insecurity of mine
especially like we didn't intentionally
do this but we kind of created like this
image on our channel of like oh we have
the perfect relationship and I we didn't
intentionally do that it's just that we
I guess we are insecure about it too so
we weren't trying to show the ugly that
mine's only natural to put your best
foot forward right the public setting
right so I guess I'm really insecure
about about that like the fact that we
have created this image but in reality
it hasn't been like that and not until
just recently if within this past year
like we're learning how to actually be
the image we've created and which means
to be happy and like to work through our
problems and like to have a healthier
relationship because honestly it was not
a very healthy relationship that we've
had and I guess I'm insecure when people
point that out like sometimes especially
in recent years I've so early on in our
in our personal channel because we
started this in 2015 so back then I was
just so vibrant so bubbly so excited and
they're just like this is such a new
thing and like I'm so excited to
document my life right now and like all
these changes happening in my life I was
just so like
more like the energy levels were higher
for our Channel but then in recent years
like you know that I've been doing this
for so long and like I just wanted to be
more of like this is how I really am and
like talk to the camera and in a way
that I would talk normally to anyone and
so it's a lot lower energy so then
people will point that out and say look
at how miserable she is in her marriage
look at how like poor Casey he should
run and all these things and like and
that's really hurtful cuz I'm like [ __ ]
you don't know all the you don't know
the work that we put into our marriage
so that's a big security of mine I guess
it's like yeah you guys don't see the
whole thing but now we really are good
and we're really working on it it's
awesome
yeah nice yeah the progress and that's
what I love this group for too is that I
never had a group of people where I
could just say my insecurities to them
you know like in the chat like how you
did and then know that they're gonna
give me some support or like I say the
thing I need to hear like Romo be
reminded of and like I feel so much
support in this group and I just love
you guys for that I guess it reminds me
that's what I like it's I really feel
like Casey and I were able to get to our
relationship where we are now cuz I'm a
lot of reasons but like a good big
reason is because like I've been able to
have you guys I was like my rock and
like really helped me get through the
stuff that we've been through um and so
yeah that's like I really appreciate you
guys for all that oh thank you I mean
that's what we hope to like include you
guys into I mean like every we're all
humans okay we're all humans trying to
do the best job we possibly can and you
know where if humans are flawed and [ __ ]
perfect okay so it's a great necklace
you can buy it from you missed out oh
damn see you [ __ ] up yeah but keep
your eye out because I'm
I mean we really we really put it out
raw here and like you you guys are part
of this circle because like elective
said you know a lot of youtubers they're
going to show you the perfect life and
we kind of suck sometimes and like if we
can help anyone not make some of the
same mistakes we did or feel the same
way about our yourselves about certain
things just by sharing our experiences
what we're going through that it's
normal and don't shoot the second arrow
and beat yourself up more when something
happens and how to overcome it if you
ever come in we'd done it like yo y'all
part of this too yeah so make sure you
subscribe and write as five stars on my
- yeah it's very important I want to
actually like really stress the fact
that what you see online everything and
their life is so perfect you should not
compare yourself to yeah because we are
flawed like I may seem perfect and
amazing and happy you have laws we have
flaws but the important thing is we're
working on it we're all people I was
trying to work on it okay so no and be
less harsh on your neighbor to like be
gentle towards other people they're
working on their own [ __ ] so we love you
guys thanks for watching - new you tune
in next time and we'll see you dick